donc l'exposé qu'on m'a demandé ce soir en
fait j'étais totalement libre de décider
du thème et j'ai décidé de parler de
quelque chose qui est je crois
dramatiquement non évalué ou non étudié
qui est le lien entre l'économie et la
physique ce que je vais à la  conclusion
à laquelle je vais vous entraîner en quelque
sorte, c'est que lorsque vous intégrez la physique à l'
économie, vous arrivez à des résultats qui
ne sont pas très faciles à vendre dans une élection
si vous regardez réellement le
discours conventionnel sur la question qui est soulevée
ici la réponse est oui oui vous pouvez
tout avoir en même temps en fait un
organe qui s'appelle l'ONU
qui est censé être sérieux ou
du moins un lieu où un grand nombre de
personnes devrait s'entendre sur des choses sérieuses
qui vous disent  que nous avons des
objectifs de développement durable 17 pour être précis et
donc ces objectifs de développement durable
devraient être atteints tous en même temps
et en fait si vous les empilez les uns
sur les autres, c'est proche d'Alice en
W  vous allez satisfaire des
économistes vous allez satisfaire des
médecins vous allez satisfaire des gens
qui enseignent quelque chose vous allez
satisfaire des féministes vous allez
satisfaire des gens qui boivent de l'eau ce qui représente
un assez grand nombre de personnes vous
allez  satisfaire les maires vous allez
satisfaire les industriels vous allez
satisfaire les consommateurs n'oubliez pas les
consommateurs bien sûr vous allez
satisfaire les gens soucieux de l'
environnement vous allez bien donc
tout le monde va être satisfait je
signifie que ce discours ou n'importe quel discours pré-électoral est à
peu près le même vote pour moi et je vais
vous apporter le bonheur qui que vous soyez
quoi que vous fassiez est
la réponse courte est non afin que nous puissions tous
sortir et boire un verre j'essaie  pour
vous donner une réponse plus longue pendant le créneau horaire
qui m'était imparti et pour vous donner la
réponse plus longue, je vais aborder
quelque chose qui s'appelle l'énergie, vous
savez probablement que nous avons un ministre
en France chargé des questions énergétiques
en fait ça fait très longtemps
qu'on a en France quelqu'un en charge
des questions énergétiques je suis prêt à parier
avec n'importe qui dans la salle que si je
demandais au ministre de tutelle ce qu'est
exactement l'énergie j'obtiendrais tout sauf le
bonne réponse, donc si quelqu'un est prêt à
parier, je prends tous les paris en quittant la
salle parce que lorsque vous posez la question
à la population en général et à la
population en général et au ministre
responsable, pensez en fait de la même
manière que la démocratie fonctionne, vous
obtiendrez  cette réponse l'énergie est une facture Je sais que
c'est quelque chose que vous payez un peu Dickie que
vous achetez en fait la première chose
à laquelle vous allez penser est votre
facture d'électricité parce que c'est la facture
que vous recevez tout le monde reçoit une
facture d'électricité essentiellement sauf pour les
tramways qui vivent  dans la rue la deuxième
chose à laquelle vous pourriez penser car un
certain nombre de personnes ont un chauffage central
qui fonctionne au gaz est une facture de gaz
certaines personnes très intelligentes pourraient thi  nk de
l'essence qu'ils achètent à la pompe
mais c'est tout je veux dire l'énergie c'est la facture eh bien
il se trouve que si vous répondez que l'énergie c'est la
facture vous venez de vous allier avec
les économistes et c'est la mauvaise réponse
c'est la mauvaise réponse parce que si vous
regardez  la taille de la facture par rapport à
tout ce que nous dépensons c'est une petite facture une
très petite facture cette courbe vous donne la
fraction des dépenses qui sont
consacrées à l'achat d'énergie ok ce qu'elle
dit c'est que sauf pendant les chocs pétroliers
ce que le monde dépense en moyenne  pour acheter du
pétrole, du gaz et du charbon et je saurai que je
n'ai pas de courbe aujourd'hui, mais je vous rappelle
que 65% de l'électricité
produite sur terre provient du charbon et du
gaz,
donc vous achetez d'abord du pétrole et du gaz: ouais, désolé,
c'est quelques pour cent de  nos revenus donc
en moyenne dans le monde vous je dépensais
quelques pour cent de nos revenus en énergie
c'est négligeable d'accord en France vous avez dépensé
un tiers de vos revenus en logement
c'est une affaire sérieuse alors vous dépensez
10 pour cent de vos reve  nue sur la nourriture, donc
presque une affaire sérieuse était d'environ
trois ou quatre fois ce que vous dépensez
quelques pour cent de vos revenus pour
téléphoner à un ami en disant que vous
allez être en retard d'accord, ce qui représente à peu près le
même montant d'argent que vous  dépensé en
énergie, donc l'énergie est négligeable dans nos
dépenses
et parce qu'elle est négligeable,
c'est quelques pour cent de nos dépenses
quand vous parlez à ou plus économique, le
réflexe qu'il aura est de dire d'accord
si c'est quelques pour cent de mes dépenses
je '  je vais traiter le sujet
quelques pour cent de mon temps et c'est tout
j'en ai fini maintenant je peux m'occuper de la
recherche de choses travail politique fonds de pension peu
importe pas l'énergie d'accord donc l'énergie je
prends un ministre pour lui donner des
instructions et désolé  le dire en
français comme Dougal l'a dit pas sur l'Autriche ce n'est pas
grave d'accord eh bien penser comme ça est à
peu près aussi pertinent que si vous disiez que mon
cerveau représente 2% de mon poids donc je peux prendre
soin de mon cerveau deux pour cent du temps
et le  le reste du temps  c'est non
ça ne sert à rien de prendre soin de mon cerveau d'accord
je peux faire ce que je veux dans mon cerveau est
juste ou je peux consacrer à quelqu'un le
soin de prendre soin de tous les cerveaux et je
vais lui donner deux pour cent de
n'importe quoi et  Je peux regarder
le reste de manière indépendante avec d'autres personnes, bien sûr, cela
ne fonctionne pas parce que notre corps est un
système de couple et si j'enlève la moitié de
votre cerveau, je ne diminue tout simplement pas votre
poids d'un pour cent et donc votre
puissance d'un pour cent.  Je vais juste vous dire
ce que je vais vous expliquer, c'est que c'est
exactement la même chose pour l'énergie, en
fait, nous ne nous soucions tout simplement pas de
combien cela coûte, ce n'est tout simplement pas le point dont nous
nous moquons maintenant, supposons que
nous avons encore  posez la question il y a une
deuxième réponse très courante qui est quand
vous entendez l'énergie vous pensez que l'économie d'énergie
est quelque chose que nous n'économisons pas encore c'est une
mauvaise réponse
si vous êtes tous dans cette pièce avec le
temps de m'écouter au lieu de faire pousser des
pommes de terre  c'est justement parce que
depuis deux siècles w  ous n'avons pas économisé d'
énergie c'est justement à cause de ça si
durant les deux derniers siècles on avait
économisé de l'énergie ce serait 500 millions de
paysans sur terre pas d'étudiants ici ou une
poignée parce que c'est à cause du
système productif le système formidablement
productif que nous avons mis en place
avec des machines que nous avons assez de temps
pour faire tout autre chose que cultiver des
pommes de terre deuxième romancier un grand nombre
de gens n'ont tout simplement aucune idée que c'est d'accord avec
eux parce qu'il y a un ministre en
charge d'accord et si vous demandez bien à un poète,
le poète va  vous donner ce qui
se rapproche le plus de la bonne réponse, c'est-à-
dire que l'énergie est quelque chose
que vous trompez un matin que vous êtes en pleine forme, eh bien en
fait c'est la bonne réponse car,
comme vous le savez probablement dans cette salle, l'énergie
est par définition en physique ce qui
quantifie le changement  donc si vous êtes
bourré d'énergie, vous êtes bourré de
la capacité de changer votre environnement
et c'est-à-dire que vous êtes bourré de la
capacité de maîtriser votre
destin  la rgie c'est par définition ce qui
permet de changer l'environnement par
définition pour cela seulement il faut un
convertisseur bien sûr on ne peut pas utiliser l'
énergie dans le mauvais sens donc l'énergie c'est
quelque chose qui permet de maitriser dans
son environnement et du fait de la loi
de conservation  que vous savez probablement
mieux que moi tout ce que nous pouvons faire concernant l'
énergie est en fait de ne pas produire ou de
produire de l'énergie, il extrait de l'énergie
de l'environnement ou il est déjà
là et l'utilise dans un convertisseur pour obtenir
quelque chose que nous jugeons utile
c'est tout ce que nous pouvons  faire avec l'énergie d'accord
l'énergie que nous obtenons de l'
environnement nous l'appelons souvent l'
énergie primaire donc quand vous lisez l'
énergie primaire quelque part c'est l'énergie qui
existe déjà dans l'environnement à savoir les
choses qui brûlent le pétrole le gaz le charbon le bois les
cascades le vent qui souffle etc c'est
l'énergie primaire bien sûr une partie de l'
énergie primaire que nous trouvons dans l'
environnement est l'énergie chimique sous
forme de produits comestibles qui est la première
énergie  y que l'humanité a utilisé et elle l'a
utilisé avec le seul convertisseur qui était
disponible à l'époque qui est notre propre
corps donc nous prenons cette énergie de l'
environnement disons Kela mammouths nous la mangeons
et cela nous donne assez d'énergie pour
rester à 37 degrés  Celsius et se
déplacer pour que nous puissions chasser d'autres mammifères d'
accord, c'est donc le premier convertisseur que
nous avons sous la main, mais aujourd'hui, grâce
à karna papa et à d'autres, nous avons découvert
un autre nombre de convertisseurs que nous pouvons
utiliser et que nous pouvons utiliser avec d'autres formes
de  l'énergie que les produits comestibles ce sont
les machines qui nous entourent aujourd'hui
partout tout le temps ces machines
nous ont permis de convertir d'autres formes
d'énergie parce que quand toi quand quelqu'un
dit que tu consommes de l'énergie en fait
c'est faux tu ne bois pas d'huile et
tu ne respires pas  gaz et vous ne mangez pas de
charbon d'accord, donc vous ne consommez pas d'
énergie en fait ce que vous faites vraiment quand
quelqu'un dit que vous consommez de l'énergie, c'est
que vous utilisez une machine qui convertit l'
en  ergy c'est ce que vous faites donc en utilisant de plus
en plus d'énergie vous devez enlever cette
expression de votre tête et penser en
utilisant de plus en plus de machines c'est ce que
cela signifie de dire que nous utilisons de plus en
plus d'énergie cela signifie que nous utilisons de plus
en plus de machines qui ont  une
capacité de plus en plus grande à créer des
flux physiques dans l'environnement c'est ce que
nous faisons vraiment lorsque nous consommons de plus en
plus d'énergie la quantité d'énergie que nous
sommes maintenant capables de faire passer par les machines est
énormément plus importante que ce que
notre propre corps est capable de fournir à mon
père parmi ses réalisations était
aussi modeste car je suis alpiniste donc c'était de
temps en temps dans les montagnes mais
ce que je vous pouvez aussi imaginer grimper
la tour Eiffel ça marche aussi alors
supposons par exemple que tous les
matins avant le petit déjeuner afin de
se sentir en pleine forme comme je l'ai dit
avant de monter disons six virgule
cinq fois la Tour Eiffel à pied pas
avec l'ascenseur l'avantage bien sûr est
que vous avez moins  Touristes japonais
lorsque vous tapez si vous faites cela et si
vous attendez 80 kilogrammes plus 10 de votre
sac à dos c'est uniquement parce que le
calcul est simple bien sûr
ce que j'utilise est la formule très basique
qui est e égale MGH
c'est aussi simple que ça  vous en arrivez à
la conclusion que tout ce que votre corps
peut produire en une journée, vous savez que dans un grand
effort qui dure une journée, c'est un
demi-kilowattheure ridicule d'accord si
vous utilisez vos jambes pour travailler, vous pouvez utiliser
vos bras ce n'est pas aussi pratique mais  si
tu utilises tes jambes pour gravir 2 000
mètres oh tu as fourni sous forme
d'énergie mécanique c'est un
demi kilowattheure ridicule complètement ridicule si
tu fais ça un jour sur deux ou tous les
jours tu grimpes environ 1 000 mètres à la
fin du  année, vous êtes capable de fournir une
centaine de kilowattheures d'
énergie mécanique d'accord, c'est l'ordre de
grandeur de l'énergie mécanique
qu'un corps humain est capable de fournir
ici si au lieu d'utiliser vos jambes, vous
utilisez vos bras pour s  taudis la terre même
chose e égale MGH tu arrives à la
conclusion que tu es dix fois plus
ridicule car avec ce genre d'
effort tu fourniras 0,05
kilowattheure sur un an d'énergie mécanique
totalement ridicule totalement ridicule d'
accord
dans un seul litre d'essence  un
seul litre d'essence et je
rappelle qu'en france on consomme à peu près
mille litres d'essence par habitant
et par an malgré le fait qu'on est
censé être tout nucléaire donc un seul
litre d'essence c'est enfermer 10
kilowattheure d'énergie thermique  et si
vous mettez cela dans une machine, bien sûr,
vous avez le contre-rendement que
vous allez retirer de cette machine de deux à quatre
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique,
ce qui signifie que dans un seul litre d'
essence, vous avez la même capacité à
transformer  l'environnement que vous avez
en dix à cent jours de dur
labeur humain que ce que les machines signifient pour nous maintenant
si vous convertissez cela en argent cela signifie
que si vous prenez la pers  là-dessus ça change
l'environnement si tu embauches cette personne
au smic ok le
kilowattheure humain va te
coûter entre quelques centaines et
quelques milliers d'euros alors que la
machine va rendre le même service car
je ne compte pas le  coût de la machine
pour un coût marginal de 10 centimes
donc passer de l'homme à la machine est un moyen de
diviser par un facteur de plusieurs milliers
à plusieurs centaines selon l'
efficacité le coût de
transformation unitaire transformation physique
de l'environnement à savoir construire un
mètre carré  de logement qui
transporte physiquement une tonne de marchandises qui
fabrique physiquement une chaise qui fait
grossir physiquement d'un carat c'est pourquoi
votre pouvoir d'achat a augmenté
c'est pourquoi vous pouvez avoir des négociations sur vos
salaires et croire que vous allez gagner
ce n'est pas parce que votre patron  est quelqu'un de
fabuleux, c'est juste parce que nous avons eu
cette augmentation de productivité de deux siècles à
cause de cela, donc la seule
raison pour laquelle  le budget de la recherche a
augmenté est là et la raison pour laquelle
il va diminuer à partir de maintenant est là
aussi on va voir après c'est
physique son physique maintenant supposons
qu'on prenne un esclave
la définition d'un esclave c'est pas
très bien  mais la définition d'un esclave
est que c'est quelqu'un que vous ne payez pas pour
son travail d'accord mais généralement ce n'est
pas quelque chose que les gens aiment beaucoup
devenir des esclaves donc quand vous avez un esclave
vous devez aller chercher l'esclave contre
son ou elle  volonté et il faut garder l'
esclave en vie donc nourrir l'esclave lui donner un
minimum de vetements il faut empêcher l'
esclave de fuir car il ne
veut pas rester esclave l'empêcher de se
taper en toi si tu peux voir Django
sauf essayer de  essayez donc vous devez payer un
certain nombre de choses quand vous avez un esclave
pour que l'esclave reste un métier à
votre service quand vous accumulez le coût
d'avoir un esclave vous arrivez à la
conclusion que même un esclave va
vous coûter cher  dix à un hu  ndred fois plus d'
argent que la Machine et la raison
pour laquelle l'esclavage a disparu dans les pays
qui ont eu accès à un
flux croissant d'énergie est juste à cause de cela,
ce n'est pas parce que votre code génétique a
radicalement changé et que vous êtes bon
quand vos ancêtres étaient mauvais votre  une fois que
vos ancêtres étaient aussi mauvais et aussi bons
que vous n'êtes ni plus ni moins le même
code génétique la différence est là la
différence est que cela n'a aucun
sens de s'embêter avec des esclaves qui veulent
vous ralentir et fuir quand la machine
qui  n'a pas tous ces
désagréments et peut travailler toute la
journée ou toute l'année et toute la
journée pour dix deux cents fois moins d'
argent c'est aussi simple que ça maintenant cette
énergie que nous utilisons a un autre avantage
ne nous coûte rien c'est  le pétrole
c'est joli non pas c'est beau j'aime le
pétrole en fait ce sont des micro-organismes
qui vivaient dans l'océan il y a dix
millions d'années à cinq cents
millions d'années ces micro-organismes
comme toute vie sur  La Terre est pleine de carbone,
ils meurent parce qu'il n'y a pas plus d'
éternels que nous et une
petite fraction de ces
micro-organismes de plus quand ils meurent tombent sur le
fond de l'océan,
ils se mélangent avec
les sédiments généraux, à savoir la poussière apportée par
le vent. les sédiments apportés  par les rivières
l'Escaut des petits micro
-organismes qui tombent aussi etc tous ceux-ci sont
enterrés dans un certain nombre d'endroits par la
tectonique donc il se rapproche de
la chaleur du centre de la terre se
cuit lentement en l'absence d'oxygène
c'est une sorte de  la distillation que vous
avez et le sédiment devient de la pierre et
vous voilà avec un réservoir oral
qui est un champ pétrolifère et c'est ainsi qu'un
champ pétrolifère est créé et si vous allez
au bon endroit et pompez avec la
pompe appropriée, vous obtenez du pétrole bien ça arrive
que tout ce processus de passage des
micro-organismes océaniques à northfield
personne n'a payé un seul centime dans la pièce
pour que le vent soit gratuit le soleil est gratuit les
huiles le libre choix le gaz gratuit est gratuit
génétique co  de bois tout type de bois est
gratuit en fait toutes les ressources naturelles sont
gratuites par convention dans le
système économique les choses sans lesquelles nous
ne serions pas sur cette terre sont gratuites par
convention dans le système économique c'est un
flux majeur c'est un flux majeur je  signifie que nous
dépendons d'un stock qui n'a pas de prix si
vous faites cela dans une entreprise privée, je peux
vous dire que vous faites faillite
c'est exactement ce que nous ce qui nous arrive en
fait à l'échelle planétaire, nous
sommes un peu gros en faillite et
parce que le pétrole est aussi  libre comme le vent c'est la
raison pour laquelle historiquement nous ne sommes pas
passés des combustibles fossiles aux énergies renouvelables
nous avons fait exactement le contraire nous avons
fait exactement le contraire et la raison
pour laquelle c'est encore une fois dans la physique
supposons que je prends un volume d'air
qui est  pas très loin du volume d'
air de cette pièce disons un cube de 10 mètres
sur chacun sur chaque type supposons que
ce vent souffle à travers une éolienne à
la vitesse de 80 kilomètres par heure bien
la quantité d'énergie avec le y  champ de
40% de la facture de vent que vous
allez obtenir
à la fin est l'équivalent de ce que vous
avez dans trois millilitres d'huile à
gauche le train quitte la gare quand
il y a du vent à droite le commerce
quitte la gare quand  vous avez décidé
que le Train va partir de la
gare à Gauche alors que vous devez
stocker de l'énergie qui vient d'une
source très diffuse comme celle-
ci donc il faut la rassembler la collecter
et la concentrer il va en falloir
beaucoup  plus de travail que d'aller creuser un
trou au milieu du désert saoudien,
c'est pourquoi, comme tout ce que nous payons, ce sont encore des hommes, la
nature n'est pas payée, donc le pétrole est gratuit, le
vent est gratuit, tout ce que vous payez lorsque vous payez, l'
énergie est le montant.  de travail et de
revenus aux actionnaires qui sont
nécessaires pour passer d'une
station balnéaire gratuite à ce que vous payez d'
accord, donc tout ce que vous payez, ce sont des hommes et
sur le côté gauche, désolé,
vous payez beaucoup plus cher que  à
droite c'est pourquoi à gauche je
ça va vous coûter quelques centimes avant le
stockage et n'importe quoi dans la gamme de 20
à 50 après le stockage tandis qu'à droite
c'est une fraction de centime de stockage
inclus c'est de la physique c'est de la physique
parce qu'à droite vous aviez quelque
chose que Nature a déjà
élaboré  très sophistiqué et
concentré sans frais donc si vous
devez le faire avec un travail manuel à gauche
ça va vous coûter un bras je veux dire
c'est aussi simple que ça à cause de la
convention économique et à cause de la
physique qui est une autre façon de dire
tout de suite que je ne crois pas une
seule seconde que nous allons remettre
pour maintenir le niveau de vie que nous
avons aujourd'hui sur terre avec 7 milliards de
personnes et juste des énergies renouvelables vous pouvez juste
oublier que cela n'arrivera jamais jamais
nous ne pourrons partir  seulement sur les énergies renouvelables
avec 500 millions de personnes et le niveau
de vie que nous avions il y a deux siècles
que nous connaissons parce que nous avons déjà fait
les expériences
pour que nous sachions que c'est possible peut-être
l  Vivre avec quelque chose qui représente le dixième
du niveau de vie actuel de
cinq milliards de personnes sur terre est
quelque chose de possible, je ne sais pas,
mais maintenir le niveau de
vie actuel une voiture pour deux personnes 40 40
mètres carrés de logements chauffés en
hiver  l'été
etc le supermarché regorge de marchandises
tout ça avec de l'énergie renouvelable pas une
seule seconde ça va arriver
jamais une seule seconde à cause de ça et
c'est la raison pour laquelle jusqu'à maintenant les énergies
quand on les a découvertes
on s'est progressivement accumulées  l'une de
l'autre les énergies que nous avons
découvertes signifiant les convertisseurs que
nous avons découverts car en passant du
bois au charbon et du charbon au pétrole en fait nous
sommes toujours passés d'une énergie à une
énergie de qualité supérieure d'une manière la meilleure
énergie que vous puissiez penser  c'est tout son
liquide donc on peut le transporter et le
stocker très facilement c'est très dense en termes
de contenu énergétique et très simple à utiliser
un moteur est un petit appareil que l'on peut
fabriquer en quantité énorme ok donc
vous n'avez rien de mieux que le pétrole ce que
vous pouvez voir ici c'est que quand on
regarde la quantité d'énergie donc à savoir la
quantité de machines qu'un homme a utilisé
en moyenne sur terre pendant un siècle
et demi le bois c'est  un peu spécial
car c'était surtout du chauffage vous voyez
qu'en plus du bois qui a lentement diminué
on a mis du charbon et aujourd'hui les deux tiers
du charbon utilisé sur terre servent à
produire de l'électricité vous avez 2 000
gigawatts de centrales électriques au charbon sur
terre dont nous devrions nous débarrasser
d'ailleurs dans les 35 années à venir, donc au
moment où les plus jeunes Indus dans la pièce auront
mon âge, d'accord,
c'est à peu près ça, nous devrions nous débarrasser de
2 000 gigawatts de centrales électriques au
charbon sur terre si nous  je veux m'en tenir à
l'objectif des deux degrés
35 ans ouais magnifique eh bien c'est l'
énergie que vous utilisez pour vous déplacer le gaz
est arrivé en tête l'hydroélectricité est
arrivée en tête le nucléaire est arrivé en tête et
maintenant la dernière chose qui est arrivée en tête
est nouvelle  renouveler  ables donc les nouvelles énergies renouvelables sont
la partie rose et c'est la combinaison
du vent solaire raz de marée géothermique
biogaz nommez-le j'oublie probablement
un ou deux courants marins et
vous voyez ici la contribution en termes
d'approvisionnement énergétique par habitant que les nouvelles
énergies renouvelables occupent aujourd'hui de  Bien sûr, un
certain nombre de personnes pensent que nous
allons remplacer tout cela par de nouvelles énergies renouvelables
en gardant à nouveau le niveau de vie et
le bas prix de l'énergie que nous avons
aujourd'hui Je doute que la réalité aujourd'hui soit
que 80% de l'énergie que nous utilisons sur terre
ce sont les combustibles fossiles la réalité aujourd'hui c'est
que si vous regardez la plus forte
augmentation de la production d'électricité au
cours des 10 dernières années on l'appelle de loin de
loin d'accord donc c'est la réalité et la
raison pour laquelle on ne veut pas de
toute cette électricité tout cet approvisionnement énergétique
diminuer c'est à cause de ça avec les
petits équivalents que je viens de
calculer avant à savoir un être humain
équivaut à cent kilowattheures de
puissance mécanique par an avec ça  quatre
pattes dix fois moins pour les armes l'ordre
de grandeur de l'approvisionnement énergétique par
habitant sur terre 20 000 kilowattheures
par an c'est l'équivalent mécanique de
200 esclaves par habitant donc si les énergies fossiles
n'existaient pas pour avoir le même
niveau de vie sur  moyenne sur terre
nous aurions besoin d'une sorte d'exoplanète
avec 1 400 milliards de personnes dessus qui
ferait du vélo toute la journée et nous enverrait l'
énergie mécanique pour que nous puissions
transformer ce que nous transformons aujourd'hui en
France le SMIC
à 500 à 600 et vous en  la chambre qui
sont généralement dans les classes supérieures
vous êtes plus de 1 000 ces
esclaves mécaniques sont les machines qui fabriquent
vos vêtements les machines qui ont
fabriqué les chaises sur lesquelles vous vous asseyez
les machines qui ont fabriqué les
bâtiments dans lesquels vous vivez et vous travaillez dans
le  les machines qui ont fabriqué la
nourriture que vous mangez les avions qui
vous déplacent parce que je sais que les
chercheurs prennent tout le temps des
avions prennent des avions tout le temps  e etc etc donc c'est
toujours les machines qui fabriquent de nouvelles
classes toutes ces machines réunies
ensemble elles représentent l'équivalent
de 1 000 esclaves travaillant toute l'année
pour vous c'est la réalité physique d'un
monde moderne apporté par cela et maintenant vous
comprenez que quand on veut  se débarrasser
de tout cela au nom de la préservation d'un
système climatique stable à propos de tout le monde
dit oui mais non oui mais maintenant voilà pourquoi
nous en sommes arrivés à une situation où nous
croyons que nous allons atteindre les
objectifs physiques que nous nous sommes fixés et
en même temps atteindre une
croissance perpétuelle c'est à cause de ses copains et de
lui-même c'est à personne de dire Joe
Batista dire fait partie des
économies classiques qui il y a deux siècles ont
conçu un ami la base de l'
économie moderne à l'époque ces gens
ont dit explicitement que
dit explicitement dans le livre que j'ai mentionné
la politique de l'économie des brevets, il a dit que
les ressources naturelles sont gratuites par convention,
pourquoi a-t-il dit cela à l'époque pour
s  quelque chose de très simple encore
il y a deux siècles L'humanité est de 500 millions de
personnes l'espérance de vie à la naissance est de 25
ans Le PIB par habitant est ridicule
donc ce que John Bautista dit correctement
pense à l'époque est qu'une
approximation du premier ordre qui est correcte est de dire
que la diminution de  les
ressources naturelles c'est quelque chose qui est
négligeable
en terme d'obstacle à l'économie
par rapport au manque d'êtres humains
capables de travailler ou au manque de
capital humain autrement dit vous dites si on
veut abattre des arbres et les amener
en ville c'est  pour frapper les villes, nous
avons assez d'arbres, le seul problème est de
trouver suffisamment d'ouvriers pour abattre les
arbres et de trouver suffisamment d'ouvriers pour
amener les arbres à Paris, c'est ce qu'il
pense d'accord, même chose car je ne sais pas
creuser pour trouver du minerai de fer dans le  les premières
mines de fer, je veux dire, c'est juste que la limite n'est pas
sur les ressources, la limite est sur les personnes
capables de faire le travail et il a dit que la
nature est si vaste, si formidable que la
diminuer de juste  un peu est
quelque chose que nous pouvons négliger et si vous
négligez ce que vous faites à la nature son
équivalent en termes mathématiques pour dire
qu'elle est infinie et donc que
toute diminution est nulle la
diminution relative est nulle donc il dit que l'épuisement
des stocks naturels est nul deux siècles
être après que nous sommes passés d'un demi-milliard
à 7 milliards, nous avons augmenté la
consommation individuelle de quelque chose
entre trente à cent et nous
considérons toujours que l'approximation du premier ordre
est la nature est zéro une approximation valide du
premier ordre désolé est la
nature est zéro  bien sûr, ce n'est pas valable,
mais penser comme ça a conduit à l'
économie moderne qui raisonne de cette façon,
fondamentalement, nous avons un système productif,
les deux facteurs productifs sont le
capital humain et le travail humain et si nous avons
ces facteurs productifs, le
supermarché regorge de choses à acheter mais  maintenant c'est
exactement la façon dont la raison donc dans cette
façon de raisonner on a deux
facteurs exogènes qui sont le capital et le travail le PIB
est sous jaloux  de ces deux facteurs
mais l'énergie est considérée comme une marchandise comme je l'ai
dit au début est un produit que vous
achetez lorsque le PIB est là et donc l'énergie est
endogène ou PIB donc avec ce genre de
raisonnement désolé d'abord vous avez assez de
personnes capables de travailler et assez  le
capital humain alors il déclenche plus de PIB puis
il appelle plus d'énergie et d'ailleurs
c'est exactement la façon dont les scénarios du GIEC
dans le stress sont conçus,
ce qui est très drôle,
je veux dire que le physicien a passé des décennies à
mettre en place des modèles qui tentent de représenter
correctement la réalité ou cela  rendre compte
correctement de la réalité physique du
système climatique et vous alimentez ces
modèles avec des hypothèses qui sont totalement
je veux dire hors du monde réel totalement hors
du monde réel nous aurions pu
écouter quelqu'un d'autre à l'époque permettez-moi de vous
présenter quelqu'un nommé shall Japan  pas
diplômé de ce lieu seulement de l'
Ecole Polytechnique désolé et en
1827 dupa calcula l'
équivalent esclave ou plutôt à l'époque l'
équivalent ouvrier de la pro
forces ductives que nous avions dans le pays, alors il a
dit d'accord dans l'agriculture, nous avons des gens
capables de travailler mais nous avons des enfants, je veux dire que la
population dans son ensemble n'est pas seulement un homme, vous
avez des femmes obscènes comptées femmes pour 1/2
désolé compté des enfants à partir de 1/  2 1/2 ou
1/3 ou 1/4 et dire que c'était 1/4 donc
ça l'amène à un équivalent pour la
part humaine des autres
forces productives c'est ok je vais vous montrer
ici ici je vous dis  ok nous avons aussi des
animaux donc j'additionne les animaux et
cela équivaut à un nombre de travailleurs
et à la fin j'arrive à la
conclusion que la puissance mécanique
que vous pouvez mettre dans l'agriculture à
cause des esclaves biologiques désolés à l'époque biologiques
qui  ces
animaux équivaut à quatre fois ce que nous avons
concernant les
copains et il dit que nous pouvons faire la même
chose pour l'industrie afin que je puisse considérer
les moulins à eau et les moulins à vent etc comme l'
équivalent des corps humains et cela
me donne aussi la force productive non
seulement de la population  mais la population
et les machines que nous avons pu
maîtriser à l'époque si bombardées
comprennent correctement à l'époque que la
production n'est pas faite par les hommes la production
est faite par les hommes et les machines et quand les
machines représentent bien plus que les hommes en
fait l'approximation au premier ordre
n'est pas I  prenez la population et le capital mais
je prends des machines et autre chose et
c'est exactement la façon de penser en fait
si vous avez des produits au supermarché,
vous avez besoin des matières premières pour produire
le produit parce que si vous avez des atomes de
cuivre dans quelque chose que vous achetez, vous
devez trouver  l'atome de cuivre ou quelque part
dans l'environnement d'accord vous ne
créez pas un atome de cuivre parce que vous
avez un crédit à la banque ne fonctionne pas
bien donc tout ce que vous pouvez faire est de le trouver dans
l'environnement et même chose en fait
pour tous les éléments  du tableau de
Mendeleïev donc si la nature n'est pas créée
pour nous et gratuitement les 92 éléments
du tableau de Mendeleev nous n'aurions
aucun parfum de PIB mais c'est gratuit d'accord donc
nous  besoin de ressources pour transformer et nous avons
besoin de la capacité de transformer ces
ressources à savoir les êtres humains au
début et maintenant les machines et la nourriture qui
leur est propre qui est l'énergie qui
compte pour 200 si l'humanité compte pour
un et là vous voyez que le
goulot d'étranglement qui va  avoir l'
importance du premier ordre ce n'est pas avons-
nous assez d'hommes mais avons-nous assez d'
énergie c'est le vrai goulot d'étranglement c'est
le seul à regarder le capital dans ce
système n'est qu'une boucle interne car
vous produisez un bâtiment exactement comme
vous  produire une paire de lunettes vous prenez des
ressources dans l'environnement la
transformer avec des machines et l'homme
en quelque chose d'autre que nous jugeons plus
précieux c'est exactement le même
processus physique la seule différence est que
les biens de consommation sont quelque chose qui est
censé être détruit lorsque vous les
utilisez  ou le détruire assez rapidement alors que
les biens d'équipement sont quelque chose qui n'est pas
détruit lorsque vous l'utilisez mais c'est la
différence maintenant si dans ce flux  vous
avez un goulot d'étranglement sur l'énergie pour une
raison quelconque vous pourriez manquer d'énergie ou vous
pourriez décider que vous allez
comprimer l'approvisionnement énergétique dans l'intérêt
du climat ne fait aucune différence
ici vous allez comprimer l'
apport mécanique des machines et  alors
vous allez contracter le
flux sortant c'est à dire la production moins l'énergie moins
les biens de consommation on va voir que
dans une minute
si vous avez moins de ressources ça marche
pareil ça marche pareil et
c'est la raison pour laquelle quand on regarde  au niveau
mondial le meilleur
modèle macroéconomique que j'ai trouvé jusqu'à présent est une
ligne droite une ligne droite sur l'
axe horizontal vous avez l'énergie qui est en
fait le nombre de machines que nous
utilisons et sur l'axe vertical vous avez
la contrepartie économique  des flux physiques
que nous avons créés avec ces
machines, à savoir des valeurs ajoutées empilées au-
dessus des autres, c'est le PIB,
c'est donc la conclusion logique d'avoir
consacré la production  aux machines qui sont
200 fois plus puissantes que l'humanité,
vous devriez vous attendre à ce que ce graphique ressemble
à ceci et c'est une question de quantité
ce n'est pas une question de prix et j'ai
une deuxième conclusion qui pourrait blesser un
petit économiste dans cette salle  s'il y en a,
il n'y a absolument aucune
élasticité entre le prix et le
volume, vous savez qu'un certain nombre de personnes disent d'
accord, vous avez un produit si vous avez
plus de ce produit, il coûte moins cher et
si vous avez moins de ce produit, il
coûte  plus mauvaise réponse
ce graphique est un tracé de la quantité de
pétrole qui est offerte sur le marché mondial
et du prix du baril de pétrole et
les points ici commencent en 1921
j'ai enlevé les points avant car
sinon ils auraient occupé
trop de place ici  et ça va jusqu'en 2015 mais
ça ne change pas grand chose si j'avais
mis 2016 si tu avais eu une élasticité les
points devraient être organisés de cette façon plus de
pétrole moins cher moins de pétrole Custer très simple
ok ce que vous regardez ici est tout sauf
ça ac  en fait ce n'est pas bijectif pour
commencer vous me donnez un prix je ne peux pas
vous donner un volume en fait si vous
regardez ce graphique vous pouvez dire que l'approximation du premier
ordre est que vous avez deux
régimes inélastiques orthogonaux un régime dans
chaque sens dans lequel désolé  le volume peut
faire ce qu'il veut et le prix
reste constant puis un autre régime
qui est l'exact opposé d'une manière
où le prix fait n'importe quoi et le
volume reste à peu près constant puis encore
un régime dans lequel le prix oscille un
peu autour d'une valeur fixe quand  le
volume change beaucoup, puis encore une fois, etc.
donc il n'y a absolument aucun lien entre
le prix nominal et le volume, donc
quiconque utilise et je connais des
économistes qui utilisent une élasticité une élasticité à
long terme parce que vous avez une
élasticité à court terme mais  une
élasticité à long terme entre les prix et les volumes
concernant l'énergie ou en fait n'importe quel
produit dans un modèle est susceptible de
vous donner un résultat qui est faux
car il n'y a pas une telle relation
maintenant o  Depuis que je l'ai dit à nouveau, la
question est de savoir ce qui se passe si nous revenons
à la question initiale maintenant, comme vous l'avez
compris, la production n'est pas
une question d'hommes aidés par des machines,
c'est une question de machines aidées
par des hommes le conducteur  du tracteur n'est
là que pour guider le tracteur ce n'est pas le
conducteur
du tracteur qui laboure la terre
c'est le tracteur d'accord donc si vous pouvez
enlever le conducteur et le remplacer par un
logiciel vous avez le même flic si vous
enlevez le tracteur et gardez  le conducteur
tu n'as pas la même marionnette donc c'est
la machine qui produit l'homme
est juste là pour donner des
ordres et c'est vrai pour les tracteurs
car la puissance d'un tracteur c'est 600
fois ou notre la puissance d'une paire de jambes
la puissance d'une machine de Travaux Publics
est mille fois d'un ordre de grandeur
la puissance de la paire de bras qu'elle
remplace
donc même chose si vous gardez la machine
et mettez le logiciel dedans vous obtenez la
même protection si vous la supprimez  e
machine et gardez le conducteur vous n'obtenez pas
vraiment la même production c'est à
cause de machines comme celle-ci plus d'autres
machines que je vais montrer par
exemple celle-ci plus les
cimenteries encore des machines plus les
aciéries encore une machine etc qu'aujourd'hui nous
sont capables de construire une tour à LA défense
en un an alors qu'il a fallu un siècle pour
construire pas de berline avec des muscles le logement pas cher
c'est des machines pas de machines pas de logement pas cher
très simple donc bourgeois c'est un
enfant d'énergie pas de détenteurs d'énergie non
un train c'est a la  même puissance que
cent mille fois
les jambes du conducteur ou cent
fois les jambes de tous les passagers
combinés, un avion est supérieur d'un ordre de
grandeur car il doit voler
et si vous regardez précisément l'aciérie,
il vous faudrait
remplacer une seule aciérie qui peut être
opérée par une seule personne il
faudrait prendre tous les habitants de la
dans les chutes mettre un marteau dans les mains
et les faire marteler toute la journée d'accord pour
ne pas s  étudier la physique ici vous
avez plus d'acier toute la journée juste pour remplacer une
aciérie si nous n'avons pas d'énergie d'accord
donc ces machines sont énormes
maintenant que se passe-t-il si nous avons moins de
machines allons-nous les remplacer par des
hommes donc si vous avez moins d'énergie  quelqu'un
peut penser qu'on va remplacer les
machines par des hommes et c'est une bonne chose
pour l'emploi malheureusement c'est une
mauvaise réponse si vous avez une machine plus
la nourriture qui lui est propre plus le chauffeur de
la machine vous avez l'équivalent prenez
un tracteur de 600  les hommes maintenant supposons
que vous contractez l'approvisionnement en énergie cela
signifie que vous allez contracter la
quantité de machines qui peuvent fonctionner et vous
dites ok c'est une bonne chose je vais
remplacer à savoir dans cet exemple la moitié de
la machine je ne le fais pas  avoir plus
par 300 hommes ce serait correct si
payer un homme c'était une fois sur 300 payer
une machine alors t'avais tu as un
équivalent économique et tu dis ok
j'enlève la machine la remplacer par 300 hommes
me coûte exactement  la même chose mais il se trouve
que ce n'est pas le cas la machine
vous coûte quelques hommes donc ce qui se passe si vous
avez moins de machines c'est que d'abord vous
allez avoir moins de PIB parce que vous
ne pouvez pas remplacer la machine par une
forêt productive qui vous coûte
la même chose
et comme l'homme n'est là que pour conduire
la machine vous avez moins d'emplois donc avec
la différence énorme entre la
productivité d'une machine
et la productivité des hommes ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui si on contracte la fourniture d'énergie
au premier ordre c'est que  nous
allons contracter en même temps le PIB et
l'emploi et je ne dis pas seulement que je le
prouve c'est l'approvisionnement énergétique de l'
Espagne l'approvisionnement énergétique de l'Espagne a culminé
en 2007 qui le savait personne d'accord ce n'est pas
dans le papier  mettre en service une nouvelle
éolienne est dans le journal tous les jours ce
n'est pas dans le journal c'est beaucoup plus
dramatique pour l'avenir de l'Europe
qu'ériger une nouvelle éolienne
beaucoup plus dramatique je peux vous dire donc l'
approvisionnement en énergie a atteint son maximum pourquoi cela  pic
parce que l'approvisionnement énergétique de notre Espagne à
l'époque était principalement du pétrole et l'approvisionnement
en pétrole conventionnel qui n'est que du pétrole
qui n'est pas du pétrole de schiste et des sables bitumineux dans
le monde a culminé en 2006 ce n'est pas dans le
papier non plus mais c'est réel donc il l'a fait
parce qu'il a culminé, l'approvisionnement énergétique
provenant de la diminution du pétrole et comme c'était
la part dominante de l'approvisionnement énergétique
de l'Espagne, l'approvisionnement énergétique de l'Espagne a
diminué maintenant, regardez le nombre de personnes
qui travaillent en Espagne par rapport à la
population, c'est quelque chose qui devrait
être utilisé à la place  du taux de chômage
parce que le taux de chômage est la
fraction de personnes qui souhaitent un travail qui
ne travaille pas mais ce n'est pas quelque chose de
pertinent parce qu'il faut demander aux
gens si on doit travailler ou pas
cette courbe ici c'est le rapport
emploi-à-  ratio de population qui est
la fraction de la population âgée de
15 ans ou plus qui travaille c'est un
indicateur physique vous n'avez pas besoin de
demander aux gens s'ils veulent le travail
ou non parce que si p  les gens ne veulent pas d'
emploi parce qu'ils ont dit qu'ils en avaient
assez de chercher un emploi ou parce
qu'ils ont dit qu'ils avaient maintenant une sorte
de formation qui, selon eux, leur
fournirait un emploi plus tard, même si ce n'est
pas vrai, etc. vous les supprimez  d'après les
statistiques du chômage, il existe donc un moyen
très simple de réduire le taux de
chômage, c'est de faire en sorte que les gens
ne veuillent plus d'emploi
ne riez pas environ la moitié des
femmes aux États-Unis ont été vendues de cette façon juste de
cette façon d'accord donc ceci  est le
ratio emploi-population en Espagne
et ce que vous pouvez voir, c'est que la
fraction de la population qui est capable
d'avoir un emploi en Espagne est loin d'
avoir retrouvé le niveau de 2007, loin
de l'avoir retrouvé, donc si vous
regardez  la dynamique d'accord la
croissance est de retour mais la croissance n'est pas de retour pour
que la situation soit devenue la même
et maintenant regardez le PIB donc c'est la
même courbe que j'ai tracée pour le monde
mais c'est pour l'Espagne ce que vous pouvez voir c'est
qu'à partir de 1969  à 2007 bien vous avez  e un
approvisionnement énergétique croissant donc à savoir un
nombre croissant de machines au travail donc
vous avez un PIB en croissance 2007 vous inversez
la courbe le PIB diminue si je reviens à
la courbe concernant l'approvisionnement énergétique
ce que vous pouvez voir en fait c'est que vous
avez un début de rebond  à partir de 2014
oui 2014 et vous avez le même rebond
sur l'emploi et le même rebond sur le PIB que
vous pouvez voir ici donc si vous voulez savoir
si les promesses électorales qui dépendent
du PIB vont être tenues ou
non il n'y a qu'une seule chose à  ne faites
rien à faire regardez l'
approvisionnement provisoire en énergie du
pays si ça monte vous pouvez croire
aux promesses si ça baisse ne croyez pas
aux promesses c'est aussi simple
que ça aussi simple que ça  bien sûr, les
politiciens ne connaissent pas cette
analyse physique de l'économie, alors ils continuent de
promettre parce qu'ils ne voient pas l'
intérêt que nous avons un ministre ministre de l'
énergie 5% de nos dépenses, ils
ne voient tout simplement pas l'intérêt que j'ai essayé de dire ceci
à un  fraction importante de la
classe politique qui rigolerait juste
penserait un fou ou penserait que je parle hébreu
que je ne regarde pas la même chose avec la
Grèce qui n'a jamais entendu parler des
problèmes de la Grèce avec
personne d'accord même histoire l'approvisionnement énergétique
de la graisse  est principalement le pétrole ou le contrat
après 2006, de même que le taux d'emploi
, l'histoire de la bande du PIB regarde le
Portugal au Portugal, l'approvisionnement énergétique se
stabilise après 2002 2003 bien,
le désolé se stabilise bien, le
ratio emploi-population diminue
un peu parce que le  le nombre d'emplois
reste constant avec la population qui
croît et le pib s'arrête d'augmenter ça
marche très bien maintenant regardez l'Europe dans l'
Europe au sens large l'approvisionnement en énergie vient
du pétrole le pétrole comme je l'ai dit c'est la
combinaison bien pas comme je l'ai dit en Europe
c'est le  combinaison de notre
production nationale la mer du Nord qui a culminé en
2000 plus les importations qui ont culminé
à l'échelle mondiale en 2005 donc 2006 désolé donc l'approvisionnement
en pétrole en Europe a diminué de 16 pour cent
depuis  e 2006 et la tendance après un court
rebond qui est due à la formidable
augmentation du prix du pétrole entre
2008 et 2014 qui a déclenché d'
énormes investissements dans la
partie amont qui a déclenché un rebond de la
production maintenant nous allons
assister exactement à l'inverse  le processus exactement inverse les
bas prix du pétrole réduisant
l'investissement en amont diminuant dans
la production de pétrole, donc cela
va encore baisser gaz si je dis gaz je suis
sûr que beaucoup de gens dans cette salle
penseront que la Russie a mal répondu
60% de  le gaz que nous utilisons en Europe
vient de la mer du nord qui a culminé en
2005 les importations sont à peu près constantes en
volume car c'est installer un nouveau
gazoduc c'est quelque chose qui prend 30 ans si
vous avez suivi l'actualité vous avez peut
être suivi l'aventure de  North
stream 30 ans South Stream on n'a
même pas donné la première pelle
au premier ouvrier donc ça va rester
des importations constantes même si on
voulait extraire du shal  e gaz en supposant qu'il y a
du gaz de schiste dont nous ne savons pas que ce
serait la limite supérieure de l'approvisionnement d'accord, donc
ce n'est pas un changement de jeu,
donc cela va également baisser pendant des
années - pour les décennies à venir
, puis appeler  avant même que le charbon ne soit un
problème pour le climat, la
production nationale de charbon avait été divisée par
trois au cours des trois dernières décennies
parce que l'Europe a été le premier continent
à commencer à extraire du charbon et maintenant le froid est
presque entièrement épuisé en Europe, la seule
chose qui reste est  un très pauvre qui s'appelle
un lignite en Allemagne mais à part ça
le reste diminue rapidement et comme
vous pouvez le voir les importations n'augmentent pas
rapidement car importer du charbon demande
des moyens logistiques qui sont énormes il
faut des ports qui se consacrent à cela
il faut des trains qui se consacrent
ce n'est pas quelque chose que vous faites comme
ça, donc quand vous regardez l'
approvisionnement énergétique de l'Europe qui est à la
pointe de la transition énergétique,
elle repose toujours sur le charbon qui a atteint son apogée
au niveau national et diminue sur le pétrole
qui a culminé au niveau national et
partiellement dans le monde et décline sur le
gaz qui a atteint un pic au niveau national et n'est
pas si facile à importer sur l'
énergie nucléaire qui a atteint un sommet dans l'esprit des
gens, nous pensons donc que nous devrions nous
débarrasser de  ça et bien sûr c'est pas avec
ça qu'on va fournir l'
équivalent de tout le reste quand tu
regardes la production industrielle tu retrouves des
choses qui rappellent la forme tu
vois ça grimpe jusqu'en 2007 baisse et
et remonte un peu et rebondit  un
peu de 2014 et bien regardez l'
indice de la construction en Europe vous avez
exactement la même chose en 2007 on est
passé par le maximum du
carré annuel B du volume annuel
de la construction puis il a baissé
rebond alito même chose
désolé ah le  l'image a été supprimée je
voulais vous montrer le camion le trafic
de marchandises dans les camions même chose
il a culminé en 2007 en Europe et c'est
le rapport emploi/population  en
Europe, il est donc inférieur en cas
de crise en raison de la part du
secteur public en Europe qui est plus élevée
que, par exemple, aux États-Unis, mais elle a quand même
diminué par rapport au maximum de l'
approvisionnement énergétique un petit rebond en ce qui concerne le
PIB par  habitant c'est exactement la même
histoire c'est une courbe qui vous montre le
PIB ou plutôt l'augmentation du PIB
par habitant au cours des 50 dernières
années et quelque chose donc en bleu vous aviez la
variation annuelle donc cela signifie par exemple
que de 60 à 61 le  Le PIB par habitant a
augmenté de près de 5%, c'est pour
vous ok de 61 à 62, il était de 4%, etc. et
en orange, vous avez la moyenne sur 3
périodes, la première période est jusqu'aux
chocs pétroliers, l'énergie par habitant augmentait
rapidement et le PIB par habitant était  croît
rapidement alors nous avons la période entre
les deux anciens chocs de 79 et 2005 et bien
l'énergie par habitant en Europe était à
peu près constante donc la quantité de machines
par habitant était constante et probablement
à l'exception de l'
efficacité énergétique  icency que nous pourrions mettre en œuvre dans
les machines chaque année et donc la
croissance de l'énergie par habitant a
diminué en moyenne à 2% et à partir de
2007 c'est le maximum de l'approvisionnement énergétique
en Europe, vous pouvez voir que le PIB par
habitant a parlé d'augmenter  en Europe
maintenant prenons une zone qui est l'Europe dans
laquelle vous avez la même
production de produits chaque année les gens sont libres de se
déplacer les gens sont libres de se
déplacer et vous avez la même production
et le même revenu moyen par
habitant chaque année sur le  les
revenus de l'ouest de l'Europe sont en moyenne 3 à 4
fois supérieurs à ceux de l'est
de l'Europe et les gens sont libres de se
déplacer que font-ils
pendant que le plombier polonais va à Londres
il contribue à faire baisser un peu les
salaires en Grande-Bretagne  et en augmentant un
peu les salaires du pauvre moyen
employé partout où il va bien, donc en fait,
ce que vous faites, c'est que vous effacez progressivement
la différence de potentiel d'une manière que vous
créez un courant, mais comme le  l'énergie en
général ne fait pas pousser tout ce que quelqu'un
gagne est quelque chose que quelqu'un d'autre
perdra d'accord et vous demandez aux Britanniques
s'ils aiment ça et j'ai dit non donc
le brexit est une conséquence directe
du fait que l'approvisionnement énergétique a
commencé à diminuer  en Europe en 2006 et
la convention économique estime que
cela n'a aucune importance c'est une conjonction
des deux maintenant je vais terminer
par une petite règle de trois que je
vais vous apporter comme moyen de
réfléchir à l'avenir  Je prends les emplois
que nous avons dans une zone donnée et je dis
quelque chose que nous devrions tous être d'accord sur des
emplois égaux emplois donc pour pas Steve Jobs
bien sûr je divise et multiplie les emplois par
le PIB vous savez que je peux toujours
diviser et multiplier par  quelque chose qui
n'est pas nul si je veux le faire en faisant cette
division j'ai créé ici un
indicateur qui est combien d'emplois puis-je
mettre dans une unité de PIB cela signifie que
c'est en fait l'inverse du terme PIB
sur les emplois qui est combien  l'argent que je donne
à som  quelqu'un qui a un emploi pour un PIB donné
ok donc ça évolue comme l'inverse
des salaires si j'augmente les salaires ce terme
diminue si je diminue les salaires ce terme
augmente ou en fait pas le salaire quels
revenus ok donc moins les gens
gagnent
d'argent pour un PIB donné  et le plus grand nombre d'
emplois que je peux mettre dans ledit PIB qui
est l'histoire des négociations sur les salaires
entre patrons et employés et je
vais encore diviser et multiplier par l'
énergie donc c'est l'efficacité énergétique
du PIB c'est combien d'euros de
valeur ajoutée que je peux créer quand j'ai transformé
l'environnement jusqu'à un kilowattheure
ok donc je transforme l'environnement jusqu'à
un kilowattheure c'est censé
créer de la valeur ajoutée à savoir si je transforme
le minerai de fer en fourchette c'est plus
pratique de manger votre  la nourriture avec une fourchette
faite avec une poignée de minerai de fer
évidemment donc j'ai créé de la valeur et
donc le mais j'ajouterai aussi de l'
énergie de temps utilisé j'ai changé quelque chose d'accord
et plus je peux créer de valeur ajoutée pour un
phys donné  flux ical et plus
mon économie est efficace bien sûr vous
avez des limites par exemple la loi Carnot
est une limite pour les
moteurs à combustion interne vous ne pouvez pas aller au-delà ok quand vous
voulez sortir Aaron du minerai de fer qui
est si ma mémoire est bonne 3 fe2o3  vous avez
besoin d'un nombre un nombre donné d'atomes de
carbone pour réduire l'oxyde que vous ne pouvez pas
dépasser ou avoir moins ou avoir plus je veux dire
c'est ce nombre et rien d'autre donc vous
avez un certain nombre de limites physiques à
l'efficacité énergétique ok ce n'est pas quelque chose
que vous pouvez améliorer pour toujours maintenant si je
regarde le passé dans le passé dans
un passé récent l'approvisionnement énergétique en Europe
au cours des 10 dernières années a diminué
a diminué d'un pour cent par an en
chiffres approximatifs l'efficacité énergétique de
l'économie sur le  d'autre part a
augmenté de 1,5% en
chiffres approximatifs jusqu'à présent, si je prends la bonne
partie de mon équation, la combinaison de
ces deux est une légère augmentation de 0,5%
maintenant si je veux conserver le même rapport emploi
/ population qui est  le même nombre
de personnes employées
même la population le nombre d'emplois
doit changer au moins au rythme
auquel la population augmente la
population en Europe aujourd'hui augmente
de virgule quatre pour cent par an donc
c'est virgule quatre pour cent c'est un moins
un ceci  c'est un virgule cinq mon équation
est équilibrée si ça ne bouge pas donc
aujourd'hui pour garder le nombre d'emplois
constant désolé le
ratio emploi/population constant
je ne dois accorder aucune augmentation aux gens
qui travaillent c'est très simple ce n'est pas
forcément agréable mais ça  est très
simple, donc chaque fois que quelqu'un gagne plus d'
argent pour son travail, il crée un petit
chômage quelque part parce que cela
ne fonctionne pas que si vous avez plus de
personnes dans l'économie qui travaillent, vous
avez à nouveau plus de PIB, cela va dans l'autre
sens,
nous sommes  en excès de personnes qui veulent
travailler aujourd'hui le facteur limitant est la
puissance mécanique et donc l'
énergie donc d'abord on a un PIB prescrit à
cause de la puissance mécanique
disponible  et cela nous donne une
somme d'argent donnée que nous pouvons distribuer
aux personnes qui font fonctionner les machines qui
signifient travailler même des recherches ils font fonctionner des
machines vous faites fonctionner des ordinateurs vous faites
fonctionner des avions indirectement ou vous bénéficiez
d'avions vous bénéficiez de voitures vous
bénéficiez de chauffages vous bénéficiez de
les gens qui impriment des papiers etc etc tu es
dans un monde de machines comme le reste de
la population donc je peux créer autant d'
emplois que l'approvisionnement en énergie me le permet
vu que ce sont les machines
qui produisent maintenant je vais finir  avec
l'accord de Paris il me
reste une minute si j'ai raison certains d'entre vous connaissent peut-
être ce graphique qui connaît ce graphique
pas grand monde ok ce graphique vient
du dernier rapport du GIEC qui connaît le
GIEC qui ne sait pas quoi  le GIEC est
plutôt ok le GIEC dont l'
équivalent français est jack est le Panel international
changement c'est l'organe de l'ONU qui a été
créé en 1988 pour évaluer la
science disponible sur l'impact de l'
humanité sur t  le système climatique d'accord, donc
ce que fait le GIEC, c'est qu'il prend tout ce
qui a été publié dans la
littérature scientifique et
évalue, désolé, pour
produire des rapports qui représentent l'
état de l'art des connaissances sur l'impact
de l'humanité sur  le système climatique d'accord
donc ce graphique vient du dernier
rapport du GIEC je pense qu'il vient du
résumé technique et il dit quelque chose
qui est très simple ici vous avez un
graphique dans lequel vous avez les
émissions cumulées de l'humanité entre
les temps préindustriels à savoir 1850  pour
faire simple, cela ne change pas grand-chose si vous
prenez 1870 et 2100, bien sûr, une partie de cela
est hypothétique car 2100, comme vous le
savez probablement, n'est pas aujourd'hui et ici vous
avez l'augmentation de la température globale
entre l'époque préindustrielle et 2100,
mais dérivez de la  les
émissions cumulées que nous avons ici
toutes ces courbes suivent le temps et en
fonction du temps elles vous donnent à la fois les
émissions cumulées et l'
augmentation de la température en 2100 et t  il se termine
à des points différents car cela
correspond à différents
scénarios d'émissions entre aujourd'hui et 2100 mais l'
important est de savoir qu'en
gros vous avez une relation linéaire donc
vous regardez les émissions cumulées
par exemple fin 2015 les
émissions cumulées de l'humanité étaient
2000 gigatonnes d'équivalent co2 et ça
vous dit qu'on s'est déjà engagé
pour un point quelque chose degrés d'
augmentation entre l'époque préindustrielle
et 2100 et comme très probablement toute l'
humanité ne va pas mourir demain
et arrêter d'émettre demain ça veut dire qu'un
tiers chose est  que vous pouvez oublier le
1,5 degré dans
c'est que c'était dans l'accord précédent
c'est à peu près aussi solide que si je disais quand
j'aurai 30 ans je vais faire ça personne ne
réagit d'accord je peux le dire si je veux d'
accord c'est de  pas d'utilité pratique si on veut
s'en tenir à l'objectif de 2 degrés ça veut dire
que l'augmentation de température est là
et donc on peut inverser le schéma et
dire qu'on a un budget carbone
quelque chose qui  t il ne faut pas aller au
delà c'est à dire 3000 gigatonnes d'équivalent co2
qu'on est autorisé à émettre entre l'
époque préindustrielle et 2100 dont
2000 ont déjà été émis donc même
s'il est tard on peut calculer comme moi
que 3000 moins 2000 égale  1000 Je pense que
nous devrions être d'accord là-dessus également et cela
signifie que si nous avons un budget de 1000 cela
reste que si le chemin des émissions est
quelque chose qui est plus ou moins
continu et qui peut même être dérivé
alors cela signifie que nous avons un point
de contrôle de  diviser les émissions par 3 entre
maintenant et le moment où mes enfants auront mon âge d'
accord c'est ce que nous devrions faire si nous voulons
des degrés maintenant revenons à mon
équation car la plupart de l'énergie aujourd'hui est
des combustibles fossiles et peut-être que nous allons
discuter  à ce moment-là mais comme la physique
nous dit que ça va être je veux dire
c'est très très improbable que tous ces
combustibles fossiles soient remplacés un par un par les
énergies renouvelables et le nucléaire dans les 35 ans
à venir
je veux dire que ce n'est pas totalement
impossible physiquement mais c'est  est proche de ok parce que
les conditions préalables en termes d'acceptation
de la population générale que tout le monde
travaille dans ce
programme et et nulle part ailleurs ne
semblent pas très très très élevées, donc
diviser les combustibles fossiles par trois, c'est
diviser l'approvisionnement énergétique par quelque chose
qui est proche  à trois et si vous
composez l'intérêt, cela vous indique que
l'approvisionnement en énergie va diminuer
de plus de trois pour cent par an
trois à quatre pour cent d'accord lorsque vous
prolongez cette courbe, il n'y a aucune
raison que vous ayez vous pouvez le voir dans
le  passé ça a été plutôt continu
et ça a été plutôt continu
malgré les chocs pétroliers que vous avez ici
et là comme vous pouvez le voir ça ne change pas
grand chose d'accord et encore vous avez des enterrements
vous ne violerez pas la loi de Carnot d'accord
donc l'idée  que nous allons partir d'
un point quelque chose que nous avons en
Europe et en fait moins de 1% que
vous avez dans le monde
moins de 1% parce que dans d'autres parties
du monde, cela n'augmente pas  et peut
parfois diminuer, cela signifie que la
combinaison des deux est liée à mon
avis à une diminution de quelque chose, donc si
vous voulez garder cela au rythme d'une
augmentation de la population que personne ne
considère que nous devrions nous arrêter de la façon dont
personne ne le dit d'accord  alors si vous
cumulez l'intérêt que vous donnez
abandonnez avec la conclusion que vous pouvez sauver
le climat mais vous ne direz pas en même
temps croissance et dire emplois si vous voulez que les
gens soient payés la même chose si vous
voulez dire climat  les gens doivent
accepter ce qui est en fait la
contrepartie économique du fait qu'on
va contracter les flux physiques et
donc contracter la production et
donc diminuer le pouvoir d'achat
c'est ce que ça veut dire et ça veut dire aussi
qu'alors les gens doivent accepter que ce qu'est
la terre  tu vas augmenter
tu es après l'Europe mais diminuer tu es
après ici la sobriété en d'autres termes en d'
autres termes est quelque chose qui quand vous
regardez cette simple règle de trois se
traduit  d'une manière évidente dans l'
économie
et ce que je crois que ce sera ma
conclusion c'est qu'au lieu de ça c'est mon
père d'ailleurs au lieu de compter sur
un miracle qui permettrait d'avoir tous
les objectifs des objectifs de développement durable
qu'on n'atteindra jamais tous
ensemble, nous sommes arrivés à un moment de
choix, nous devons donc choisir soit nous disons
ok le feu d'artifice va
continuer aussi longtemps qu'il pourra continuer un
an 5 ans 10 ans 20 ans ce qui
se passe après on s'en fiche c'est
quelque chose  qui a sa logique interne
vous pouvez considérer que ce n'est pas moral mais
il a une logique interne et l'autre
chose qui a une logique interne c'est de
dire qu'on veut que l'humanité vive aussi
longtemps qu'elle le peut dans des conditions ni trop mauvaises ni
trop mauvaises  et puis la
conclusion évidente c'est qu'il faut contracter l'
économie aujourd'hui quand tu dis à un
économiste ce que je viens de dire encore une fois il
te regarde sauf une poignée comme si
tu étais fou et la raison pour laquelle encore une fois
remonte à  vomi c'est-à-dire et le
fait qu'avec les bases qui ont été
jetées sur la table à l'époque où les
économistes ont créé le système
sans limite apparente il n'y a rien dans
la théorie économique qui dit quand le
PIB va atteindre soixante dix mille
cinq cent trente  quatre milliards de dollars
ça s'arrête n'a pas ça d'accord tu as
en physique quelqu'un qui dit quand tu
as fait le tour de la terre après P marées
douze mille et quelque kilomètres
tu es revenu au point de départ
tu connais exactement la valeur d'accord donc tu
sais exactement  quelle est la limite et dans la
plupart des théories physiques vous avez ce
genre de limite que vous pouvez exprimer en
termes très précis vous n'avez rien de tel
dans la théorie économique et la
raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui, d'une certaine manière, les pires
ennemis de la
préservation de l'environnement sont les
économistes  c'est parce que la prise en
compte des limites physiques qui viennent
de l'environnement les obligerait
à jeter deux siècles de
réflexion accumulée et à revenir à  zéro
et ils ne le feront jamais
merci merci votre argument pour la corrélation du PIB et de
la consommation d'énergie est assez
bon assez convaincant mais dans l'
équation la simple règle de trois que vous avez
montrée le PIB ne semble pas être une très bonne
mesure de je veux dire vous  Je parle de la
qualité de vie du mode de vie, mais le PIB n'est pas
une très bonne mesure de la qualité de vie, je
suppose et, comme dans vos graphiques précédents,
vous avez quadruplé sur
un ou deux siècles la
consommation d'énergie par habitant, mais  Je pense que
par rapport à 1800, la qualité de vie par
je ne sais pas comment la mesurer correctement
qu'elle a augmenté de plus de quatre
fois est-il donc possible d'aimer avec
une efficacité énergétique plus élevée en termes de
qualité de vie énergétique comme différents
choix de mode de vie de  bien sûr, mais une certaine
qualité de vie étant élevée moins d'
énergie utilisée ne pourriez-vous pas aimer maintenir
plus de bien-être car avec moins d'énergie
il y a deux ou trois questions dans
votre question donc ça va
la première chose est que G  DP n'est pas un
flux ni un stock la qualité de vie
dépend entre autres des stocks donc
l'augmentation du PIB est allée de
pair avec le fait que nous avons
épuisé de nombreux poissons dans l'océan que nous
avons épuisé de nombreux stocks de
combustibles fossiles plus élevés  épuisé de nombreux stocks de
minerais, etc. vous ne tenez pas compte de cet
épuisement dans le système économique Je
vais vous donner une première réponse en
termes économiques pour comprendre que vous
avez probablement entendu parler de la
Station spatiale internationale, le prix de la
Station spatiale internationale
est  100 milliards de dollars pour ce prix
tout ce que vous obtenez tout ce que vous obtenez est une pression d'
une atmosphère quelque chose que la nature a
fourni pour de
l'air respirable gratuit quelque chose que la nature a
fourni gratuitement
vous n'avez pas de gravité pour ce prix
quelque chose que la nature fournit gratuitement
ici
vous avez  un cycle d'eau très basique ok
donc vous pouvez boire à nouveau ce que vous venez de
faire pipi et vous avez la possibilité
de ne pas geler vous êtes protégé contre
la température extérieure  erature qui n'est pas
très sympathique ça donc c'est ce que vous
avez en gros pour 15 milliards de dollars
par personne parce que vous avez 6
habitants dans la station spatiale internationale
donc je peux dire que le prix du
système terrestre est d'au moins 15 milliards de
dollars par habitant sur terre  au moins d'
accord au moins parce que vous avez cela et
bien d'autres sur terre vous avez aussi des terrains
sur lesquels vous pouvez faire pousser des pommes de terre que vous
n'avez pas dans l'ISS vous pouvez avoir du
poisson que vous n'avez pas sur l'ISS
encore une fois nous en avons beaucoup  des choses
ok aujourd'hui je peux aussi dire que si vous
regardez le taux d'épuisement des
ressources naturelles dites terres cultivables dites
forêts dites poissons dites ou dites combustibles fossiles
dites je ne connais pas la concentration de co2
dans l'atmosphère le taux de changement
est  généralement plus de 0,1% pour tout ce que je
veux dire, le taux de variation de l'
épuisement des combustibles fossiles est de 1% par an.
Chiffres approximatifs, le taux d'épuisement d'
un certain nombre de minerais est à peu près
de la même ampleur que le r  ate d'
épuisement du poisson est de la même
ampleur etc disons je prends 0,1% de 15
milliards de dollars par habitant ça veut dire
qu'une motorisation du capital naturel est au
moins équivalente à 15 millions de dollars
au moins équivalente à 15 millions de
dollars par habitant et par an  et de
l'autre côté vous avez le
PIB par habitant qui est de 15 000 $ 1 000
fois moins donc ce que nous faisons en ce
moment vous dites que nous améliorons notre niveau
de vie
je dis que nous brûlons le capital quand vous
détruisez ce que vous avez hérité de
votre  parents d'aller jouer à la
roulette au casino vous faites exactement
la même chose vous détruisez votre capital
pour une augmentation passagère de votre
niveau de vie c'est exactement ce que
nous faisons aujourd'hui vous pouvez le voir dans les deux
sens
vous pouvez dire que j'ai augmenté  mon niveau
de jeu et je peux rejouer la réponse d'accord,
ça ne va pas durer longtemps parce que
vous faites essentiellement cela en détruisant
votre capital même chose dans mon entreprise si
j'augmente tout le monde et pour ce faire,
je  perdre de l'argent chaque année ça ne
va pas durer très longtemps ça ne
va pas durer très longtemps donc c'est à
cause de la convention économique qui
disait que les ressources naturelles étaient gratuites
que toutes les économies croient que nous avons
augmenté notre niveau de vie nous avons
augmenté  notre espérance de vie qui est
physique nous avons augmenté la taille de
la population sur terre qui est physique d'
accord nous avons augmenté l'espace de logement
par habitant d'accord avons-nous augmenté la
capacité de voir l'avenir avec espoir ce n'est
pas si sûr d'accord donc nous avons un jeu des
choses  et des choses perdues et je ne le fais pas et
vous pouvez voir les deux sens ne pourrais-je pas décider
de ne pas jouer à la roulette et d'aller à la
plage et de profiter des couchers de soleil et c'est
oui d'accord et je suis heureux et Mays un autre
endroit si vous faites ça  vous acceptez de partager
votre chambre avec neuf personnes venant de
Syrie et normalement c'est
exactement ce qu'est la sobriété je
veux dire vous avez moins que ce que vous partagez c'est
exactement ce que c'est donc l'équation aujourd'hui
est si  nous voulons durer plus longtemps nous
devons consommer moins c'est à peu près ça
donc c'est la réponse à la première
question la réponse à la deuxième
question est le PIB est un mauvais indicateur maintenant
c'est un très bon indicateur de ce qu'il
représente c'est le PIB  Le PIB
est a été construit pour une chose donner
la contrepartie économique de la
transformation de l'environnement que
nous effectuons dans le cadre de nos
activités productives les services dans gdb
oui mais les services ne sont pas immatériels le
transport est dans les deux services il
consomme énormément d'énergie l'informatique  c'est dans
deux services
il arrive que fabriquer des ordinateurs
et les éléments des réseaux euh
ça autant que la flotte mondiale de camions
chaque année donc croire que les services
se dématérialisent c'est aussi quelque chose
qui est un mauvais terme qui a été utilisé
pour journal par des journaux  mais c'est faux
la réalité physique c'est que c'est
totalement faux quand on trace la
consommation d'énergie par habitant dans les pays par
rapport à la fraction de service  s dans
l'activité, vous avez une très forte
corrélation positive et une autre
raison est que pour avoir une
grande partie des services, vous avez besoin d'énormes
quantités de flux physiques, car
sinon vous n'avez pas besoin de ces services,
laissez-moi prendre un exemple si vous
fabriquez  une tasse par an très vite
vous pouvez vous débarrasser de tout le
secteur des assurances concernant les voitures très rapidement vous
pouvez vous débarrasser de tous les banquiers concernant le
crédit automobile très rapidement vous
pouvez vous débarrasser de tous les gens qui apprennent aux
gens à conduire etc etc donc  l'idée que les
services peuvent avoir une vie autonome
séparée de l'industriel Bittner
mais c'est juste ce que j'explique donc
c'est un système couplé et dans un
système de couple c'est la même chose c'est une
blague disant qu'avec mon cerveau au début
on ne peut pas supprimer  une partie et dire que l'
autre partie va dire à l'État
de s'excuser, la même chose ne fonctionne pas et les
services sont apparus parce que nous avons
une énorme industrie à flot à cause de
cela  permettez-moi de le dire dans l'autre sens
supposons que demain matin j'ai surpris le
réseau mondial ok demain matin
plus d'ordinateurs croyez-vous que nous
fabriquerons encore autant de voitures
vendent autant de voitures ont autant d'
avions volant dans le ciel que de bateaux
embarquant des marchandises  dans les ports car beaucoup d'
usines tournent etc etc
bien sûr non bien sur non car pour commencer
t'as plus de sacs les
banques aujourd'hui sont des services informatiques ok
t'as plus de banques donc l'idée
que les services matérialisés remplacent
les services matériels est totalement fausse quand
tu  regardez la réalité physique en
fait la plupart du temps, ils aident le
secteur industriel à prospérer la plupart du
temps et à finir avec un PIB CA que vous
savez a été inventé pour compter les tables et les
chaises et les voitures et des choses comme ça,
donc en fait c'est un moyen énorme  cet
argent est ce que nous avons inventé pour
comparer un certain nombre de choses qui ne sont pas
comparables donc fondamentalement nous avons donné une
valeur à toutes ces choses et empilé tout
cela  et c'est le PIB c'est ce
qu'il mesure et rien d'autre et rien de
plus et si vous comptabilisez correctement l'
inflation qui est aujourd'hui à peu près faite
pour les biens communs pas du tout faite pour les
actifs si vous coupez correctement parce que la majeure partie
de l'augmentation du PIB des dix dernières
ans est l'inflation des actifs qui n'est pas
actualisée dans le calcul du
PIB, mais si vous actualisez correctement l'
inflation, le PIB reflète essentiellement le
nombre de choses que les gens peuvent acheter,
donc si vous avez moins de PIB, ils
peuvent acheter moins de choses une autre bonne
question est de savoir comment  organisez-vous la
société la société pour que vous ayez encore
un contexte raisonnablement paisible avec
ce bonsoir vous nous avez montré
différentes courbes avec le PIB par rapport à la
consommation d'énergie avec une
relation linéaire mais par exemple dans le
pays comme le Danemark le PIB a doublé
depuis  les années 70 sans augmentation de la
consommation d'énergie alors comment en tenez-vous
compte dans vos modèles car les
frontières ne sont pas les mêmes  la
consommation d'énergie est quelque chose qui est
domestique le PIB prend en compte
les flux physiques qui se produisent en dehors du
Danemark lorsque Maersk
exploite un bateau qui va du Brésil à
disons l'Afrique du Sud une partie des
revenus provenant de l'exploitation de ce
bateau sont situés au Danemark mais l'
énergie  la consommation qui permet à ce
revenu d'exister est située en dehors du
Danemark donc quand vous avez un petit pays
désolé de dire petit pour ce marché quand
vous avez un petit pays qui est très
ouvert au commerce international ce qui est le
cas pour le Danemark et d'ailleurs aussi le
cas pour la Suède un autre pays que je
connais assez bien en ce qui concerne son cadre économique que
vous pouvez avoir en Suisse est
exactement le même, vous pouvez avoir de l'argent qui se
déverse dans le pays mais l'énergie
qui se déverse ailleurs, c'est pourquoi
la relation côte à conséquence
parce que c'est  une côte à conséquence d'
abord vous avez l'énergie puis vous avez le PIB
parce que vous pouvez transformer est une
ligne droite pour le monde comme un w  trou parce que nous
n'avons pas de commerce avec Mars donc les
limites sont les mêmes pour l'énergie et
pour le PIB quand vous regardez un seul
pays c'est quelque chose qui est valable
si le commerce est quelque chose qui est dans
des proportions relativement petites par rapport à
l'économie du  pays et s'il se
voit raisonnablement stable dans le temps,
c'est pourquoi j'ai choisi les
pays d'Europe du Sud et s'il y a aussi un
changement très rapide qui n'a pas parce
que ce que vous avez mentionné pour le Danemark était
un changement continu, il ne s'est pas produit du
jour au lendemain quoi  J'ai montré que pour l'Espagne, le
Portugal et la Grèce sont plus proches d'un
changement du jour au lendemain, ce qui fait
cela, alors il est valable de montrer que vous
pouvez voir l'effet quand c'est quelque chose de
beaucoup plus progressif, vous pouvez
conserver les revenus du musc
au Danemark ou de la laine de roche ou  quoi que ce soit
et avoir les flux qui cèdent la place à
ces revenus à l'extérieur et vous pouvez voir qu'un
certain nombre d'autres pays sur terre
ne les ont pas montrés ce soir dans lesquels l'
efficacité énergétique  l'efficacité de l'économie
graduée au cours des 50 dernières années en fait
c'est le cas en Espagne c'est aussi le
cas si j'ai raison aux Philippines en
Thaïlande au Vietnam en Turquie dans un
certain nombre d'un certain nombre de pays ont
dounya et dans la zone non ocde  l'
efficacité énergétique de l'économie n'a
changé que de 5% au cours des
50 dernières années, 5% au total, pas par
an, il n'y a donc pas de règle écrite indiquant
que l'efficacité énergétique devrait
s'améliorer avec le temps. Je veux dire, cela dépend, vous
devez examiner des cas précis.  ok oui
vous avez montré la courbe avec l'énergie et le
PIB pour l'Espagne et je me demandais si vous
parliez du temps autour de la
crise du temps de la crise de 2008 eh bien
il y avait un pic et je me
demandais le sens de la causalité entre
le le  diminution du PIB et la diminution
de la consommation d'énergie parce que vous pourriez
aussi dire bien ouais et aussi la deuxième
question concerne la courbe la
relation année-ligne
il semblait qu'au sommet de la courbe
le PIB le faisait  moi très étrange de me
courber et oui je me demandais si vous
pouviez donner à n'importe quelle occasion le pic est 2007
ici si vous regardez le PIB en fait le
point d'inflexion est 2007 mais le
PIB maximum sur l'axe vertical est 2008 et le
fait que la courbe est  entre guillemets tourner à
gauche signifie que c'est d'abord l'énergie
qui circule qui ralentit puis le DGP
qui ralentit donc si j'avais montré deux
courbes énergie et PIB toutes les deux normalisées
car j'avais ça aussi vous aurez
vu qu'il y a un décalage d'un an entre
le  le pic de l'énergie et le pic du
PIB
donc c'est clair et c'est facile à
comprendre en termes physiques si vous avez en
fait c'est un système de couple aussi si
vous avez plus d'énergie vous pouvez transporter
plus de choses et créer plus de PIB si vous
avez plus de PIB cela signifie  que vous avez
plus de choses et parmi ces choses, vous
pouvez avoir des investissements qui vous permettent d'
extraire plus rapidement l'énergie restante donc
c'est un système de couple mais si vous regardez
si vous effectuez des choses qui ressemblent à
Granger causal  ity test vous verrez qu'avec
le temps c'est surtout l'énergie qui fait tourner
le PIB et la chose qui est
absolument certaine c'est qu'avec ce
rapport de 200 entre la puissance des machines et
la puissance des hommes vous pouvez facilement
comprendre que si vous privez les
machines d'énergie  vous allez priver le
PIB d'une partie de ce qu'il était je veux dire c'est
évident merci beaucoup vous